- Welcome.
It's so exciting to see you all here.
It's great to see everybody
and have everybody.
Thank you so much for
coming out on this cold day.
I'm Stephen Pitti,
professor of History
American Studies in ERM
and Director of Yale Center
for the Study of Race,
Indigene Transnational Migration,
which has helped to support this event.
Really happy to remind you at the outset
that we in New Haven here
are sitting on territory
that's long been the home of
Mohegan, Mashantucket Pequot,
Eastern Pequot, Schaghticoke,
Golden Hill Paugussett,
Niantic, Quinnipiac and other
Algonquian speaking peoples,
and that we continue
ourselves to be revitalized
by their survivance every day.
We're delighted to help support this event
as our ITM, along with Ezra
Stiles College at Yale.
And I want to thank a number of people
for making this happen,
Kathy Dunn and Mark
Levinson in Ezra Stiles,
Nicole Edwards and Maggie
Katz and Mary Taylor Lewis
and Victoria Stone Kana in our ITM
and the Andrew W Mellon Foundation
for providing the funding
that made this event possible.
Let me also recognize
that we have today with us
the Poet Laureate of the
state of Connecticut,
Antoinette Brim-Bell, who's here
and who has joined us today.
(audience clapping)
Thank you Antoinette, for being here.
I've also asked before we turn the podium,
or so-called, over to
our guests here in front
to just say a few logistical words.
First, I wanna make sure everybody knows
that the Yale University Art
Gallery closes at 5:00 PM
so if that, if you left any
belongings in the lockers
in the art gallery, you're gonna
need to retrieve those now,
or at least before five o'clock,
'cause the gallery will be closed.
You won't be able to get
back into the lockers
for your keys, your wallets,
your jackets, and all the rest.
So please do go fetch things
from the lockers before 05:00.
There's really no way
to open up the building after that time.
Second, although I'm not
demonstrating it now,
the Art Gallery requires
the use of face masks
in this space so please,
please remain masked
throughout the event while you're here.
That's very important to our
speaker and to all of us.
Third, wanted just to alert everybody
that this event is being recorded.
You'll see there's a camera in the back
and there may be other cameras,
so just wanted to make sure
that you're aware of that.
Finally, logistically, we're
gonna open the program up
for audience questions in
the last roughly 20 minutes
of our event today, so
please, when that time comes,
if you do have a question,
use the microphone,
which I think will be circulating.
So that our guest can hear
you and so that everybody else
in the room can hear you as well.
I'll add that at the very, very end
we'll have time for audience
members to come forward
to request a book signing by Ada Limón
at the end of the event,
around six o'clock.
It's gonna be pretty
short, we have a hard stop.
It'll be a pretty quick
session, but we'll do our best
to accommodate as many people
as want to have a book signed.
I'm gonna get outta the way,
but as I leave the stage,
I have the pleasure of
introducing the real host
of this event, Professor
Alicia Schmidt Camacho,
(audience clapping)
whom I know quite well.
At Yale, Professor Schmidt Camacho
is the head of Ezra Stiles College.
She's a faculty member in and former chair
of the Program in Ethnicity,
Race and Migration
and she's a scholar whose
work has focused on migration,
the US Mexico border, Latinx studies,
and other top topics and fields.
I'll avoid staying too
long to sing her praises,
but I'll just invite you
to join me in thanking
and welcoming Alicia Schmidt Camacho.
(audience clapping)
- Okay, this is really
beautiful. (giggles)
I have the joyful task of introducing
the 24th Poet Laureate, Ada Limón,
and opening our
conversation this afternoon.
What a gift it is to be together.
Thank you, Ada Limón, for
giving us this occasion
to gathering community
in the service of poetry.
Ada Limón, as you know, grew
up in Sonoma, California
and resides in Lexington, Kentucky,
where she writes and teaches.
She's the author of six books of poetry,
including "The Carrying," which won
the National Books Critics
Circle Award for poetry.
She hosted the Celebrated
Poetry podcast, The Slowdown
and her new book of poetry
"The Hurting Kind" is out now
from Milkweed Editions and is a candidate
for the 2023 Southern Book Prize.
And I wanna thank my colleagues
at the Yale Center for the
Study of Race, Indigeneity
and Transnational
Migration for the students
and colleagues in Ezra
Stiles and around campus and
in Ethnicity, Race and Migration
and other communities who've
shared the love of poetry
with me and shared so much with me.
And I wanna give special
thanks also to our host,
the Yale University Art
Gallery for welcoming us
and I wanna thank someone
else who's not here,
Vaughn Fielder,
representative for Ada Limón,
who runs something
called The Field Office,
where she makes the most
exquisite books and broadsides.
Please look for it.
Before we begin, I wanna mention
how marvelous it has been
to prepare for this occasion.
Ada, your arrival has helped
give us a chance to gather
and be in celebration,
something we needed.
We in Ezra Stiles,
we've began talking about
inviting Ada Limón some time ago.
And since we announced the visit,
I keep hearing testimony
from so many people about all
that her poetry and her work
has represented for them.
And in the week between
drafting my message of inquiry
and actually sending it,
Ada Limón was named the Poet Laureate.
But you were our Laureate first.
(audience laughing)
And I don't remember many moments
where I actually could trust
my government's judgment,
(audience laughing)
least of all, in anything as
important as poetry and art.
But the Office of Poet Laureate
housed in the Library of Congress
may be the one authority in the land
to whom I will happily submit.
(audience laughing)
And it was beautiful to watch
the Librarian of Congress,
Carla Hayden, name you to this post Ada,
to talk about your poetry
being a force in the world.
One that fosters connection,
intimacy, healing,
one that invites us to the table.
And Tracy K. Smith, also a Poet Laureate,
called you a poet of ecstatic revelation,
whose poems offer deep wisdom
and urgent vulnerability,
driven by language that
feels not only beautiful
but permanent and powerfully
wrought like a mountain.
That is certainly how we've
experienced your work here.
Your poems have been integral
to our life as a community.
They've given us a language
for finding one another,
for coming together in difficult moments,
for imagining living beyond
the time of pandemic,
for imagining how we can thrive.
Thank you.
And so I'm gonna begin,
move over here so that we
can begin more conversation
and Ada can face out to see all of you.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you.
- Can you hear me?
Okay. Oh, yes you can.
(both laughing)
So my favorite moment,
when you were at the Library of Congress,
was right at the beginning
after you'd been announced
and you stepped up and
you greeted everyone.
You sort of announced
your arrival in this post
and you said, "We roll deep." (laughing)
We roll deep.
(Ada giggles)
And it was a moment of recognition for me
because I think again, like
what are we trying to do here?
We're trying to gather ourselves together
to build power together
in something precious.
Precious, the way that art is.
Precious, the way that
art a accompanies us
in our lives when we need it.
How we be together.
And so it struck me that we roll deep
was kind of an artist statement
as well as a mission for you
in this role of Poet Laureate
and I wanted to ask you about that
because in your art you
contain multitudes, you know?
Your art brings multitudes.
- I love that. Thank you so much for that.
I feel like it's-
First of all, beautiful introduction.
And it's just such a gift
to be here with you all.
Thank you for coming out.
And I think one of the things
that I've always sort of, pushed against
is that sort of myth
that we make art alone.
And that that myth that
like one person rises,
I just don't believe it.
I have always believed that
we make art in community,
even if what we're working on
aren't exactly collaborations.
What we're actually doing
is often reaching out
to one another and saying,
"Hey, will you read this one poem?"
Or "Hey, will you listen to this song?"
Or "Hey, will you come to this play?"
You're always reaching out
and you're always getting
that support from the people you need.
And that to me is all part
of the art making process.
And so when I'm saying we roll deep,
I really do believe that we do that
even if deep means two people, right?
I'm not saying you have
to have this huge network
of people to support you,
sometimes you need one
other person, you know?
That just says, "Yeah, yeah,
yeah, this, keep doing it."
And sometimes they don't
even need to critique it.
Sometimes it's better if
they don't. (laughing)
Sometimes it's just better if
they say "Yes, keep going."
But I think it's important to remember
that sometimes it can look
like one person is doing a lot,
in reality, a lot of people
are doing a lot of things
and all of us are in community.
- Thank you.
And Ada, as I told you earlier today,
at the onset of the pandemic,
we really had to reinvent
the university, you know,
for the conditions of
separation and isolation.
And that's really hard.
And one thing that arose, I
think in many parts of the world
were these chain mail messages.
And I was lucky to be
receiving messages with poetry
and then the instruction would be,
"Here's this poem, now
you have to send your poem
to these 10 other strangers."
And it went around
and it was international and
eventually, you know, I was
getting repeats from people,
so it was clear that this was
doing some great work, right?
And your poems were there.
- Oh.
- More often than not.
The one that I always put
out there was "Dead Stars".
That one really works on me.
But then when I took up my
post as the Head of College
and was writing a weekly
newsletter, my dean,
Dean Temples here with me,
we were trying to figure
out how to build connections
to students and to build
a sense of community
across many time zones for
students who were in spaces
where, maybe learning was
the last thing on their mind
during the especially difficult days.
How do we be present for them?
How do we invite them in?
And how do we have the
conversations about things
that we really need to talk about, right?
And again, your poems gave me a way
to give a piece of something beautiful,
something to think about,
but most often, really invite people in.
And I put a lot of
different poems out there
and I did notice that the ones from you,
I kept hearing more.
And then also when students
were sending me ideas for poems
that they wanted to hear, they
were sending me your poems.
- Oh, I love that.
- And I've been thinking a lot about that
because there's a lot
of really very beautiful
poetry out there, right?
But there was something about,
your attention to the world,
your attention to emotion,
that really, I felt
like, was what we needed
in the university at that moment.
The university sometimes presents itself
as a space of learning where
we leave emotions aside
to achieve or to accomplish.
And we receive wisdom but,
in your poetry, there's the knowledge
that we're really struggling
sometimes, you know?
That we're kind of a mess
and that we might hurt.
And that that's actually
the best we can be right now
is true to what we're feeling.
And it felt to me like the
students were able to commune
with you and then through you, me,
because you made that space
and poetry made that space.
And I wanted to ask you to maybe think
about the way you think about emotions
and also that I know you're a teacher,
how you might think about
the teaching in your poetry.
- Yeah, thank you.
That was really beautiful.
I think that one of the big
things for me is that there's,
people will say things like,
"Oh, poetry can do this."
Or "Poetry can do that."
Or "You should read a poem and
it'll make you feel hopeful."
And we were laughing today, it's like,
"Well that depends on what poem you read."
(audience laughing)
You know?
Because if you read Philip Larkin's poem
about the groundhog, I don't
think you're gonna feel
very hopeful after that poem.
And so I think that there's a
lot of, sort of misconceptions
about what poetry can do.
And I think it's only because
it limits it, you know?
And for me,
I think it's not just that
it makes you feel one thing
or another, it makes you feel happy,
it makes you feel hopeful,
makes you reconnect with
some sort of, you know,
long lost feeling that you have to dig up
from someplace you've been suppressing it.
I think it's really that
it just makes you feel,
and I think that is important.
And I think that we've
been living at a time
where we've just had to
numb so much of our lives
and a lot of that is necessary.
Like I don't even think
that's necessarily a bad thing
that we've had to numb things
because it's really hard
to feel all the things
that we've been feeling.
And I think poetry is that way
of sort of tapping into that
and being able to like,
"Oh, right, I am a thinking,
feeling human being going
through all of these things.
I have these complex
emotions working within me."
And in doing so, feeling
like, "Oh, I'm reminded
that this is what being
a human being is like.
It's not just putting my head down
and getting from point
A to point B," you know?
It's not just survival,
can it also be flourishing?
You know, can it also be
witnessing, experiencing?
And I think that's a big part
of what I've been trying to do
with my work for a long
time, which is like,
can it help me each time I write a poem,
recommit in some way to the world
that each time I go to
the page, I'm saying,
"Here I am, I'm here."
You know?
It's like a map that says, "You are here."
Each poem is like, "You are here."
And that I think, feels just
as important as something
that might, perhaps, contain more answers
or wisdom or knowledge.
Poetry doesn't do that.
It contains more questions
and the questions lead to more questions.
And in that it's just
sort of accepting that
that fluidness of life
and that this amorphous
aspect of changing and growing
and being more in tune with ourselves.
You know, the great
poet, Sadie Wright said,
"The goal is not to make a story
but to experience the whole mess."
And I think about that all the time
because we kind of wanna do
this tidy thing in our head,
this is what happened.
But really, you know,
our jobs are just to
experience the whole mess.
- And something pretty
extraordinary happens
in the way you guide
us to that mess, right?
And you hold us there.
It seems to me that it's no accident
that the volume before "The Hurting Kind"
was "The Carrying", right?
There's so much required of us
to be carrying
and yet that caring is also
the richness of life, right?
And that's our vehicle for
joy and fullness, right?
That's the capacity to do that.
And I just, you know, like many people,
I went to funerals in the last few years.
We've seen a lot of violence
in the last few years.
Intimate violence as well as
terrifying terror in the world
and one of the things
that I noticed is that,
it's like a saying now to
say, "There are no words"
when you're greeting someone in grief,
but of course there are, you know?
And that always seemed to me like,
why are we letting ourselves
off the hook, right?
How do we be present in these moments?
How do we actually create
the language we need?
So again, I turn your poetry
because I think you're attentive
to where fear atomizes us
and pushes away from each other.
And you're not afraid to look
for language for the unsayable
to gesture towards what is
unsayable and to leave it there
for us to disentangle.
And so I'm gonna give
you an example of a line
that lives with me now.
It's part of my mental
and spiritual furniture,
again, from "Dead Stars,"
"I am a hearth of spiders these days.
A nest of trying."
There's so much happening there. Mm.
And earlier today when we
were talking with students,
which is beautiful,
you used the word ongoingness as a thing,
as something that is both
what we are tasked to do,
but is also glorious.
What a gift to experience
our own ongoingness!
So again, I just wanna
invite you to talk about,
you're tapping into something for us there
and it's a lesson, but it's a lesson that,
it seems hard won, so I wanted to ask you
how you've thought about that?
- Yeah, thank you for that.
I feel like
there's so much grief and
processing that we have to do
to just live. (laughing)
To just live.
And it's funny 'cause we can think
that we don't have to grieve, right?
And then like six months
later you're like,
"Ugh, what's happening?"
You're like, "Oh right,
I am grieving this thing
that I didn't go through," you know?
Or, "That I thought I was fine"
and I think that that
keeps happening to us.
And there's not just the
grief of the pandemic,
but there's the species
loss and the plant loss
and like the planet itself
grieving from our own harm
and all of these things
that we're processing.
And I think it's like anyone else,
it's very easy for me to
shut down to it, you know?
I'd much rather have a drink
and binge watch Netflix
than think about all the
wounds I wanna carry, you know?
But at the same time,
I know that if I'm not working
through some of that stuff,
not all of it, I can't take it all on,
but maybe a little part of
it, a little edge of it.
And if I can kind of tease it out
and work through it a little bit,
I know that I will be saner
and I know that I can be kinder
to other people 'cause It's my
way of being kind to myself.
And so in a lot of ways I think about,
there's this great Buddhist
monk named Lama Rod Owens.
I don't know if you know him.
He talks about that the goal is longevity.
And I think about that a lot
because it's very easy to think like,
"I just need to get through the day,"
or "I just need to get to
5:00" or whatever it is,
or "To get to hand this final in,"
or "To get this project done
and then I can start to
think about other things."
And he talks about longevity
because the way that we burn out, right?
The way that we burn out as
artists or whoever we are,
is by not dealing with some
of these big ticket topics
and just trying to sort of suppress them
or trying to take them all on at once.
And then wondering why in a year from now,
we can't write anything, you know?
So I keep thinking about,
a lot of my poems are also
a way of care taking myself
and a way of recognizing that my need
to be alive and witnessing the world
is a need that I would like to continue
and so sometimes when
I'm going into the well,
I have to give myself that ladder out.
Like I have to be like,
"Okay, you've spent some
time down here, good for you.
Now, where are the stairs?
You know?
And I think that's
really important for us,
not only as artists, but as human beings.
It's like, it's one thing
to face the darkness,
but it's another thing to
know that you have a way out.
And I think that that's very
much a part of me making poems,
that it's not just about,
I love when they land with someone
and how they land with someone
and hearing how it's affected.
It's like it's deeply emotional to me
and a little overwhelming
sometimes to hear someone say,
"Oh, this moved me," I love that.
But oftentimes when I'm making the poem,
I'm not thinking about that.
I'm thinking of, "How do I
get really honest with myself"
and "How do I say something
that feels unsayable?"
And then, "How do I create
spaces within the poem
where I can breathe a
little bit," you know?
And some of those poems
turn towards the light
and some of them turn away
but hopefully there's enough
balance in them as they go
that it feels like there's
a sense of wholeness there.
- You've used a word a couple times
in this conversation, "witnessing."
- Yeah.
- And it is there in your early poems,
but it is sort of a structuring
idea in "The Hurting Kind".
- Mm hmm.
- And,
I think of it as something
that you have developed
as a,
vocation in this work that you do
and I was thinking about how
you think about that term
because there's so much
in "The Hurting Kind"
about being a witness
and not needing the
things you're looking at
to give you anything back.
In fact, the fox is
completely indifferent,
the birds are indifferent, right?
And, but the task of witness is a constant
and it's a process that
is revelatory for you
and for us by reading.
And the witnessing is so often directed
toward the non-human world
and is often a way of affiliating
us with a non-human world.
And you've just spoken about that a bit.
And then I thought there's something else
that's really powerful about
your concept of witness
that I think we forget, we
think witnesses is us seeing,
attending and speaking to something,
but you really want us to
be there with our bodies.
You're attentive to the
body is a witness, right?
You know, the body is to be present
and the body experiences the
world and we have to make space
for how the body is in the world.
And there's a the beautiful
moment where the body is fragile
and you say, "The body is so body" and I-
- (laughing) It is, so body.
- As a person who lives in a body
that is a bit puzzling sometimes.
- Yeah.
- I was like, "Oh, it's so body.
- But I just wanted to ask
you to talk a little bit
about witness and what that means for you.
- Yeah.
I love that question and the
many different layers to it.
I feel like there's, you know,
to start with the body that
sounds like a Creeley poem.
He has that line right?
About the body, "The plan is
the body, the plan is the body"
he just says that over and over again.
It's wonderful.
I think that there's a level in which I,
because I have an undergraduate
degree in theater,
I was taught about the body as a tool
and the body as instrument.
And so when I moved to poetry,
breath work and you know,
sort of the "isness" of
the body was in the poems,
because that's how you make things
was to encourage the body's presence
to be present within the body.
But I too, and I love that
word you said, "puzzling"
a body that can sometimes be puzzling.
Who doesn't have a body that
can sometimes be puzzling?
Especially at a time where
they ask us about symptoms,
it's like, "I think
I've had every symptom."
My friend Kristen Dombeck,
who's a wonderful non-fiction writer,
said she just wants to write
a book called Symptoms,
which is just all the symptoms
that all of her women friends
send her just on a daily basis.
Like, "So what are the symptoms today?"
And so I think that I live
in a body that's, you know,
oftentimes in pain.
I have, I try not to say
the word chronic pain
because I believe it will someday go away.
But I do live in a body
that's a little more difficult
to get around sometimes than others.
And I experience vertigo
and I have scoliosis.
So there's these, just
things, that kind of keep me
from being completely,
totally free in the body
and so I think when I write my poems
and I think about witnessing,
I'm thinking about how are all the senses
and I can't witness without being like,
well if I'm witnessing and
I'm taking a deep breath,
you think, "Oh my back hurts a little bit
when I take a deep breath," right?
There's all these other
things that are in the body
when I do that.
I used to love it when,
meditation teachers would say,
"Just sit and be in the body."
And I'd be like,
"Well, what if the body is the problem?
(audience laughing)
You know?
I was like the one person on Zoom.
I was like, when the one
person on Zoom that I was like,
"Oh, finally, I just get to be a head.
I've always only wanted to be a head."
(audience laughing)
I was like, "This is amazing!"
Now it's like, "Okay body, we can do it."
And so I think that that witnessing
had to include the blood,
the body, every part of it.
And there's this funny when you talk
about that moment about it,
because I remember in one of the poems
when I was writing "The Hurting Kind",
having this moment,
it was during when we
were all really isolating
and we weren't, see I wasn't even,
it was just waving to neighbors
and feeling very alone.
And I just literally crawled
on my belly onto the grass
and just like laid
there and got really low
and I kept thinking this
is like low snake energy.
And I was like, "I'm just gonna
have some low snake energy
and see what happens."
But it was this way of being like,
"Okay, how do I witness from down here?
How do I witness from up here?"
And then I thought about all
the different animals and birds
that are like seeing what they're seeing
from their different viewpoints, right?
The birds that kinda
twist their head and turn
and look at you upside down.
And the trees, how they're
witnessing you from up there
but they're also,
we're standing on their roots, you know?
They're just underneath us all the time
and all those different viewpoints
and how that connects us
and how strange it is
that we think it's like,
just the poet going into the
world being like, "I see this."
- Yeah.
- Right?
But that's not how poetry happens.
It's often like, "Oh, I wonder
what that bird thinks of me?"
And all of that is in
tandem with, of course,
like how the body is also
nature, and is also animal.
And that feels very important
to my work and my life.
- Thank you.
(Ada giggles)
And will you read for us?
- Yes! I will read for you.
What if I said no?
I would be like, "No!"
(audience laughing)
Yes, of course I will read.
I shall go to the podium.
It's like a whole
different area over there.
(audience laughing)
We'll turn this off.
Can you hear me okay?
- [Audience] Yes.
- Great.
We were laughing that I was like,
"Well we can just kind
of, take it as it goes."
And then we realized that
we were both talkers.
(audience laughing)
So we're like, "No, we
actually need to keep an eye
on the time to be respectful of everyone."
So I thought I would read,
I think it's gonna be,
I'm gonna guess 10 poems.
I'm gonna give you that number
to make you feel a little,
modicum of control, (laughing)
in the otherwise uncontrollable situation
that is the poetry reading. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
You can count down or count
up however you feel like.
I'm gonna start with this poem
that is in "The Carrying",
which is, I think speaks
to some of the things
we were just talking about
in that conversation.
Sort of, looking for some
ways to caretake the self,
but also sort of denying a kind of wisdom.
And I like to tell you a little
bit of the background of it,
which is that it is a poem
that I initially wanted it
to start the collection and my
editor was like, (blows air)
"No, that's a lot.
And then also I'll say that
it was a prompt that was,
it was the Academy of American Poets
asked me to write a poem
that would be the first
poem of the year in 2016.
and of course it was, how do you do that?
They're like, just set
the tone for the year.
(audience laughing)
So, and it was a hard year.
And so this is the poem,
"The Leash."
"After the birthing of
bombs of forks and fear,
the frantic automatic weapons unleashed,
the spray of bullets into
a crowd holding hands,
that brute sky opening
in a slate metal mall
that swallows only the unsayable
in each of us, what's left?
Even the hidden nowhere
river is poisoned orange
and acidic by a coal mine.
How can you not fear humanity?
Wanna lick the creek bottom
dry to suck the deadly water up
into your own lungs like venom?
Reader, I wanna say, don't die.
Even when silvery fish after fish
comes back belly up,
and the country plummets
into a crepitating crater of hatred,
isn't there still something singing?
The truth is, I don't know.
But sometimes I swear I hear it,
the wound closing like a
rusted over garage door
and I can still move my
living limbs into the world
without too much pain, can still marvel
at how the dog runs straight
toward the pickup trucks
break necking down the
road, because she thinks
she loves them, because
she's sure, without a doubt,
that the loud roaring
things will love her back,
her soft small self alive with desire
to share her goddamn enthusiasm
until I yank the leash back
to save her because I want
her to survive forever.
Don't die, I say, and we decide
to walk for a bit longer,
starling's high and fevered above us,
winter coming to lay her cold corpse down
upon this little plot of earth.
Perhaps we are always hurdling our bodies
toward the thing that will obliterate us,
begging for love from the
speeding passage of time,
and so maybe, like the
dog obedient at my heels,
we can walk together peacefully,
at least until the next truck comes."
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
Thank you. My dog loves poems about her.
(audience laughing)
She's a pug, so you know, she's,
everyone's like, "Oh pugs are so funny."
And I was like,
"No, they're funny because
they're very serious."
(audience laughing)
(Ada laughing)
And this is a poem that
I wrote for my mother,
and one of the students
I met with today said
that she read this book with her mother
and so thought I would read this.
The poem that began with the ending for me
and then I built backwards,
which I think has only ever
happened one other time for me.
"The Raincoat"
"When the doctor suggested surgery
and a brace for all my youngest years,
my parents scrambled to
take me to massage therapy,
deep tissue work, osteopathy,
and soon my crooked spine unspooled a bit,
I could breathe again
and move more in a body unclouded by pain.
My mom would tell me to sing songs to her
the whole 45 minute drive
to Middle Two Rock Road
and 45 minutes back from physical therapy.
She'd say, that even my
voice sounded unfettered
by my spine afterward.
So I sang and sang, because
I thought she liked it.
I never asked her what
she gave up to drive me
or how her day was before this chore.
Today, at her age, I
was driving myself home
from yet another spine appointment,
singing along to some maudlin
but solid song on the radio,
and I saw a mom take her raincoat off
and give it to her young daughter
when a storm took over the afternoon.
My god, I thought,
my whole life I've been under her raincoat
thinking it was somehow a
marvel that I never got wet."
(audience laughing)
And then I'll read this poem
because it was mentioned
and you can hear the poem
that actually this began with.
A sound, which was the sound of
recycling bins rolled out altogether
and how it sounds like thunder?
You know, there's like that
little moment where you're like,
"What is that sound?"
And you are like, "Oh, it's thunder."
And then you realize
it's just your neighbor
with the recycling bin.
(audience laughing)
Of course it's not about that but,
that's what sort of came in my head.
"Dead Stars"
"Out here, there's a bowing
even the trees are doing.
Winter's icy hand at
the back of all of us.
Black bark, slick yellow
leaves, a kind of stillness
that feels so mute it's in another year.
I am a hearth of spiders
these days, a nest of trying.
We point out the stars that make Orion
as we take out the trash,
the rolling containers a
song of suburban thunder.
It's almost romantic
as we adjust the waxy blue
recycling bin until you say,
'Man, we should really learn
some new constellations.'
And it's true.
We keep forgetting
about Antlia, Centaurus,
Draco, Lacerta, Hydra, Lyra, Lynx.
But mostly we're forgetting
we're dead stars too,
my mouth is full of dust and
I wish to reclaim the rising-
to lean in the spotlight
of streetlight with you,
towards what's larger within us.
Look, we are not unspectacular things.
We've come this far, survived this much.
What would happen if we
decided to survive more?
To love harder?
What if we stood up with the
synapses and flesh and said No.
No, to the rising tides.
Stood for the many mute
mouths of the sea, the land?
What would happen if we
used our bodies to bargain
for the safety of others, for earth,
if we declared a clean night,
if we stopped being terrified,
if we launched our demands into the sky,
made ourselves so big
people could point to us
with the arrows they make in their minds,
rolling their trash bins out,
after all of this is over?
(audience clapping)
And I'll read just one
more from "The Carrying"
and then I'll move on
to "The Hurting Kind."
And you guys can hear me okay?
Okay, how are you doing out there?
(audience laughing)
Are you good? Okay, good.
I had this incredible pleasure of
going to Mexico City to
be a part of the Fandango
that was a celebration with Dr. Biden
and Dr. Gutierrez-Muller,
who's the First Lady of Mexico,
though she doesn't like
to be called the First Lady of Mexico,
she just likes to be
called Dr. Gutierrez-Muller
And she sat next to me on stage
and read this poem, in English!
And I got to see her do that
and it was really emotional for me.
This is a poem I wrote, yeah,
as a letter poem for my
dear friend Natalie Diaz.
It's the first poem in our series.
"Cargo"
I wish I could write
to you from underwater,
the warm bath covering my ears-
one of which has three marks
in the exact shape of a triangle,
my own atmosphere's asterism.
Last night, the fire-engine
sirens were so loud
they drowned out even the constant bluster
of the inbound freight trains.
Did you know, the R. J. Corman Railroad
runs 500 feet from us?
Before everything shifted
and I aged into this body,
my grandparents lived
above San Timoteo Canyon,
where the Southern Pacific Railroad roared
each scorching California summer day.
I'd watch for the trains,
howling as they came.
Manuel is in Chicago today,
and we've both admitted
that we're travelling
with our passports now.
Reports of ICE raids
and both of our bloods are
requiring new medication.
I wish we could go back to the windy dock,
drinking pink wine and talking smack.
Now it's gray and pitchfork.
The supermarket here
is full of grass seed,
like spring might actually
come, but I don't know.
And you?
I heard from a friend you're
still working on saving words.
All I've been working on is napping,
and maybe being kinder
to others, to myself.
Just this morning, I saw seven cardinals
brash and bold as sin in a leafless tree.
I let them be for a long
while before I shook the air
and screwed it all up
just by being alive, too.
Am I braver than those birds?
Do you ever wonder what the trains carry?
Aluminum ingots, plastic,
brick, corn syrup,
limestone, fury, alcohol, joy.
All the world is moving, even sand
from one shore to another
is being shuttled.
I live my life half afraid,
and half shouting at the trains
when they thunder by.
This letter to you is both."
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
If you were counting, just six more to go.
(audience laughing)
Begin with this poem
for my stepmother who passed away in 2010,
a lovely human being.
And also one of my favorite plants,
which is one of the first signs of spring.
It's probably here too.
You have Forsythia?
Yeah, it's a prose poem so it
reads a little differently.
I'll read it so you can hear the sound.
"Forsythia"
"At the cabin in Snug Hollow
near McSwain Branch creek,
just spring, all the animals are out,
and my beloved and I are lying
in bed in a soft silence.
We are talking about how we
carry so many people with us
wherever we go, how
even when simply living,
these unearned moments,
are a tribute to the dead.
We are both expecting to hear
an owl as the night deepens.
All afternoon, from the porch,
we watched an eastern towhee
furiously build her nest
in the untamed forsythia
with its yellow spilling
out onto the horizon.
I told him that the way I
remember the name forsythia
is that when my stepmother,
Cynthia, was dying,
that last week, she said
lucidly but mysteriously,
'More yellow.'
And I thought yes, more yellow,
and nodded because I agreed.
Of course, more yellow.
And so now in my head, when I
see that yellow tangle, I say,
'For Cynthia, for Cynthia,
forsythia, forsythia, more yellow.'
It is night now.
And the owl never comes,
only more of night
and what repeats in the night.
(audience clapping)
That one always does something to me.
I say that like someone else wrote it.
(audience laughing)
I was like, whew, that
one really gets to me.
(Ada chuckling)
Let's see,
I wanna read a poem
about
rethinking old myths.
We were talking about that before
and I think that there's,
it's important sometimes
to just let go of things
that people have told
you or you've held onto
that feels like just not true
or maybe just not useful anymore.
I used to have people who would say,
"Oh, you always do this"
and I think I am like that.
And then five years later I
was like, "I'm not like that."
And this is a time when right
when my parents got divorced,
I had a woman,
a mother of a friend of
mine come up and say,
"I'm so sorry you're
from a broken home now."
And I remember thinking,
"Oh, my home is broken?"
Like I didn't, I thought
it seemed okay actually.
I was like, "They seem a
lot happier, to be honest."
(audience laughing)
Anyway, so right in the middle
of the early days of the pandemic,
when we still weren't seeing
anyone masked or unmasked,
this poem came to me with the first line,
"Joint Custody."
"Why did I never see it
for what it was, abundance.
Two families, two
different kitchen tables,
two sets of rules, two creeks,
two highways, two stepparents
with their fish tanks or eight
tracks or cigarette smoke
or expertise in recipes or reading skills.
I cannot reverse it, the record scratched
and stopping to that
original chaotic track.
But let me say, I was taken
back and forth on Sundays
and it was not easy but
I was loved each place.
And so I have two brains now.
Two entirely different brains.
The one that always misses where I'm not,
and the one that is so
relieved to finally be home."
(audience clapping)
And then I'll read this poem.
You know, maybe like many of you,
if you're having a bad day or
you're stressed or anxious,
you just watch animal videos
(audience laughing)
and it's just like you
just like push replay.
Like I need to see that
bird doing that thing again
or that cat eating the most
cat food it possibly can
out of the bowl.
Or whales, I love just videos of whales.
This is one about a mountain lion.
And of course oftentimes
I say this is about this.
And then there's a lot of other things
that are at play I hope, (chuckles)
(audience laughing)
I'm feel like I'm being very
reductive to my own poem,
"The Mountain Lion."
"I watched the video clip over and over,
night vision cameras flickering
her eyes an unholy green,
the way she looked the
six-foot fence up and down
like it was nothing but a speed bump
then cleared the man-made
border in one impressive leap.
A glance over the shoulder, an annoyance,
an, as if you could keep
me out, or keep me in.
I don't know what it was
that made me press replay and replay.
Not fear, though I'd be
terrified if I was face to face
with her, or heard her
prowling in the night.
It was just that I don't think
I've ever made anything look so easy.
Never looked behind me
and grinned or grimaced
because nothing could stop me.
I like the idea of it though,
felt like a dream you
could will into being.
See a fence? Jump it."
(scattered audience gasps)
(audience clapping)
I'll read this poem
for my grandfather
and my grandfather on my father's side,
my paternal grandfather, abuelo paternal.
And he was (speaks Spanish)
And he came from Mexico
when he was quite young
and was a foster child.
I read this poem because I
wanna bring him into this space
and also think about all
the people that were artists
but maybe didn't get a
chance to be artists.
And I think sometimes we can
feel like we're making art
and it maybe it's like I feel
like I need to keep this poem
in my heart when I'm like
running through the airport.
You know? Very glamorous life.
Trying to like glide into
the plane being like,
"Don't leave without me!"
And be like, "I'm doing this
because I get to do this."
And I think sometimes we need to say that
about lots of things in our lives.
"Heart on Fire."
"As a foster child, my grandfather learned
not to get in trouble.
Mexican and motherless, dead
as she was from tuberculosis,
he practiced words in a new language
and kept his slender head down.
When the other boys begged him
to slip into the music shop's upper window
to steal harmonicas for each
of them, music being important,
thievery being secondary, he refused.
When the cops came to spot the boys
who robbed the music store,
they could easily find the ones
spitting broken notes into the air,
joyously mouthing the stainless steel,
mimicking men on street
corners busking for coins.
But not my grandfather,
he knew not to risk it all
for a stolen moment of exaltation.
It's easy to imagine
this is who I come from,
a line of serious men who follow
the rules, but might I add
that later he was a
dancer, a singer, an actor
whose best roles ended up
on the cutting room floor.
A cutup, a ham who liked a good story.
Who would have told you life
was a series of warnings,
but also magic.
Once, he was sent for a box of matches
and he put that box of strike-anywheres
in the pocket of his
madras shirt and ran home,
he ran so fast to be on time, to be good,
and when he did so, the whole box ignited,
so he was a boy running
down the canyon road
with what looked like a heart on fire.
He'd laugh when he told you this,
'A heart on fire,' he'd
say, so you'd remember.
(audience clapping)
And then I'll read just three more poems.
This is a poem that
I wrote actually for Greenpeace.
And it was right after the
fires in Sonoma of 2017.
It was on a thread on
Twitter the other day
and it was all these apology
poems and it was great.
I went on it on the plane
and it was like all of
these people were sharing
their favorite poems that
had apologies in them.
And I was like, what a great,
you could teach a whole course
on just an apology poem.
So I thought I would read this
'cause it reminded me of my own poem.
"Salvage"
"On the top of Mount Pisgah,
on the western slope of the Mayacamas,
there's a madrone tree that's
half-burned from the fires,
half-alive from nature's
need to propagate.
One side of her is black ash
and at her root is what
looks like a cavity
hollowed out by flame.
On the other side, silvery
green broadleaf shoots
ascend toward the winter light
and her bark is a cross
between a bay horse
and a chestnut horse,
red and velvety like the
animal's neck she resembles.
Staring at the tree for a long time now.
I am reminded of the righteousness I had
before the scorch of time.
I miss who I was.
I miss who we all were,
before we were this,
half alive to the brightening
sky, half dead already.
I place my hand on the
unscarred bark that is cool
and unsullied, and because I
cannot apologize to the tree,
to my own self I say, 'I am sorry.
I am sorry I have been so
reckless with your life.'"
(audience clapping)
Let's see here, I'll read this poem.
That's another prose poem.
Do you guys know the
instrument the jaw bone?
Let's say it's an actual
jawbone of a horse or a donkey
and it makes most amazing music.
"Instrumentation."
"If I could ever play
an instrument for real,
I like the idea of playing the jawbone,
the rattle of something
dead in your hands.
The thing that beats
back at the sky and says,
'I'm still here.'
Even though clearly the donkey isn't here
or the horse isn't here.
Just the teeth and the jaw
making music like resurrection
or haunting or just plain need.
What I like most is that
the jawbone is an idiophone,
which I misread once as idea phone.
But an idiophone is
just that it makes music
by the whole thing
vibrating without strings.
I want that, that kind
of reeling in the wind.
All the loose dry teeth, all
the old bones of the skull,
all the world and the figure
swaying with its stick
to make untuned music
even death cannot deny.
(audience clapping)
And I'll close with this poem
and then if you have any
questions you can ask.
This is a poem that I wrote
during the very early days of the pandemic
and people would call me
and ask me about, you know,
isn't it true that we need
poetry now more than ever?
And I was like, is it true?
I feel like we need lots
of things like healthcare
(audience laughing)
and a vaccine
and (laughing)
different modes of support.
But while this was happening,
I was also making a list
of subjects that I felt like,
I'm certain many of you who
are writers know this feeling
where I've already written about
that I can't write it again
or I've done that before and
so it just became this list
of things in my head.
And then of course what happened
was it turned into a poem,
"The End of Poetry."
Enough of osseous and
chickadee and sunflower
and snowshoes, maple and
seeds, samara and shoot,
enough chiaroscuro, enough
of thus and prophecy
and the stoic farmer
and faith and our father
and tis of thee, enough of bosom and bud,
skin and god not forgetting
and star bodies and frozen birds,
enough of the will to go on and not go on
or how a certain light
does a certain thing,
enough of the kneeling and the rising
and the looking inward and the looking up,
enough of the gun, the drama,
and the acquaintance's suicide,
the long-lost letter on the dresser,
enough of the longing and the ego
and the obliteration of ego,
enough of the mother and the child
and the father and the child
and enough of the pointing to the world,
weary and desperate, enough
of the brutal and the border,
enough of can you see me, can you hear me,
enough I am human, enough I
am alone and I am desperate,
enough of the animal saving
me, enough of the high water,
enough sorrow, enough
of the air and its ease,
I am asking you to touch me.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Alicia] Come forward
and direct the question.
- [Host] Please cue in the center aisle,
a few minutes before six,
we'll cue you that last question or two,
if you have a question.
- I know it's pressure
'cause it's like a microphone
and it's right there.
(audience laughing)
Oh yes, A brave one.
- [Audience Member] What
is your favorite poem?
- My favorite poem of all time?
That's a great question.
It changes because sometimes
I need a certain poem
and that poem becomes my favorite.
And then sometimes I need another poem.
But I think Elizabeth Bishop's "One Art"
might be my favorite poem.
Thank you for that.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] Is
this working? Oh, okay.
This is so satisfying.
Hi.
(audience laughing)
First of all,
like this reading is like the
highlight of my week, so I'm.
- I'm so glad. Thank you.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
I'm, it was amazing.
Especially like the
last poem, I think like,
there's this Instagram account
called Poetry is Not
Luxury and I'm pretty sure,
I feel like I saw that on there
and now I wanna read more.
But like, anyways,
so like to get to the point,
I'm wondering what you think about cliches
and like what the role of
cliches has been your work
and if there's ever a point
where you're just like,
have I written everything
I will ever write
for the end of time?
Like how do you pick
yourself up from this space
that like,
artistic paralysis and
like working with cliches
or maybe working with like
being more direct in your poetry
and like maybe swapping
figurative language for just like,
this is how I'm feeling
viscerally right now
and I just need to get it out on a page.
- Yeah, that's a great question.
I really appreciate that.
I'll say that there's two things
that I'll say is that one,
I feel like it's all about interrogation.
So it feels to me like
when there's a moment
where I'm just saying the
direct thing or it feels direct,
I ask myself like, is that direct?
Is that the thing? Or
is there more going on?
And sometimes the figurative
language comes into that
or the imagistic language or
maybe it just needs sounds
or something that will
actually explain it further
or elucidate it more
so that it's not just the feeling anymore
or the straightforward thing,
but that it builds into
something that's just my own.
And that is something.
So it's like always asking the thing,
you know, is this true?
Is this really, is this true?
And then the other part
I will say is that,
especially with cliches,
is that I love cliches.
I think they're wonderful
and they exist for a reason.
And then what's really fun
about them is to tug them
and pull them apart to start going like,
"Okay, so why did we say
I have a poem that's about
that idea of it's always
in the last place you look
and how silly that is."
Like, well of course it
is 'cause you found it.
But I like the poem,
sometimes just taking a cliche
that someone says and
then pulling it apart
and looking at it.
In my book, "Bright Dead Things,"
I have a poem called "Downhearted"
and it's about this idea
of picturing the heart actually down
and that it's sunk to
the bottom of your torso,
that's downhearted
and that it's on a couch
pulling up the blankets over its head.
So I think sometimes it's just about
interrogating the cliche
and then breaking it apart.
- [Audience Member] Oh, thank you so much.
- Yeah, of course.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] I had a
class and I showed up very late.
So I apologize if I'm out of breath
and if this was covered at the start,
but as someone who's not a
poet and sort of admires poets,
could you describe a little
bit what the editing process,
specifically for a poet of
your caliber, looks like?
Because I think in the
few interactions I've had
with poets my age, who are very talented,
it feels very different
than pro's editing.
And also my imagination tells me that
at least when I'm editing pros,
I kind of know what I'm writing
about from the beginning.
But poetry, I feel like there are times
when a new day brings
sort of a new perspective, a new image.
What does that look like?
- Yeah, that's great.
- [Audience Member] How do you know
when a poem is done?
Which also feels more
tricky than perhaps pros.
- Yeah, these are both great questions.
Revision to me is actually,
I think, really fun.
But it is primarily where
the writing happens in poetry
because we're working with such tiny units
it's so small that
everything is compressed
and everything is sort of
vibrating with the intensity
of that white space around
it, that silence around it
so that it has to become,
sometimes it feels like you have a tweezer
and you're just moving pieces
of rice around the page,
but they're very important
pieces of rice, you know?
But I think for me, a lot of
it's about the sound quality.
And so I compose out
loud and I edit out loud
so that I'm reading the
poem over and over again.
I'm listening for places
where I've either cut the line too short
and the breath doesn't catch up with it,
or I stumble on it each time.
Or I'm looking for a place where I'm like,
oh, this is actually,
I love sound work, so it's easy for me
to kind of get into the
consonance and assonance
and all the fun alliteration
things, and then be like,
"Okay, calm down Ada,
you know you don't need
to do acrobatics right now,
just move the machine forward."
So a lot of that is sound work.
And then the other part is
looking to figure out if,
like when you asked about,
coming to it like a
different day and being like,
well, what was the intention?
Oftentimes I'm asking, okay,
what is the intention
of this original poem?
Like what is original draft
and how can I stay true
to what the poem wants to do
without it becoming just sort
of where I want it to go?
Or maybe I started with this idea
that I wanted to write a poem about this,
but then the poem wanted to do
something entirely different.
And usually what happens is
when I revise and I fail,
it's because I'm like, "No, no, no,
I wanted to write a poem about this,"
but I'm not looking at what
the poem is actually doing.
And the poem is often wiser than we are.
And it feels like the poem
really isn't happening
until it has taught us something,
which the opposite of prose,
where you start with this
idea, and you're like,
okay, I kind of kind of
know where I'm going,
even though you, of course,
you learn as you go,
and that's why we write.
But there is this level
in which with the poem,
it really does sometimes
just come at you and go,
"Oh, I didn't know that this was
what it was supposed to teach me."
And so I think that moment has to happen.
And that's also similar to
like how I know it's done,
is that there's something that feels,
maybe not like a
conclusion, but a wholeness,
a completeness, something that feels like
whatever it began as, it has fulfilled.
- [Audience Member] Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] Hi,
thank you for being here.
I have a related question.
I read somewhere, and I hope this is true
and I'm not making it up,
that you started to write
fiction and realized somehow
that you were a poet and
not a fiction writer.
And I'd love to hear
more about that moment
and what that felt like
and what exactly tipped
you into that conclusion.
- Okay, so not entirely off base,
(audience laughing)
but I'll say this, I was always a poet.
I had three books out and
then I decided I wanted
to try my hand at fiction.
And so I, you know, quit
my job and I was like,
"I'm gonna be a full-time writer,"
which I don't know why I
thought I could do that,
but I guess it turned out okay actually.
But I moved out of New York
and moved back to California
and I did write a novel.
Well, I mean many drafts
of a failed novel or a
project that I learned a lot from.
(audience laughing)
And as I was writing that novel,
what happened was I was
spending so much time
in the life of other characters,
which I wanted to do,
because after three books
of poetry, I was like,
"Okay, that's like
enough of myself," right?
And then what happened was
then during the evenings,
I would still kind of feel
like writing something,
but I would wanna write
these observations.
I would wanna write a
little bit about myself.
And that's really how the fourth
book, "Bright Dead Things",
came into being, which was,
it was almost like a byproduct
of this novel I was working on
because I was storing up all
these poems inside of me,
and they would just come out
like fully formed all the time.
So, yeah.
So you're not, I had always
started as a poet, but I did,
that book does really kind
of take some of its life form
from the novel.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- Yeah, of course.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] Hi there.
Thank you so much for
being here and doing this.
This was really lovely.
- Yeah. Thank you.
- [Audience Member] I was wondering,
in your appointment as Poet Laureate,
and all the books you've had,
I'd imagine those are
very codifying experiences
in sort of your identity
as a poet and as a writer.
And so I was wondering
what sort of inspired you
to keep creating and to keep writing
in moments when you've
maybe had more doubt
about your place as a writer
or as a creative person?
- Yeah, you know,
I think that there's a lot of times
where it's very easy
to get down on oneself,
no matter what you do, and
it happens to me still.
And there was moments where I think,
"Oh, well, now that this
appointment has happened,
I'll never write again."
It's very easy for me
to turn anything into,
I'll just never write again.
(audience laughing)
And sometimes,
like if I write a poem
I'm really excited about
and people are like, "This is great,"
as soon as I get very elated, you know,
I pour myself a cocktail and
two seconds later I'm like,
"Well, I guess that's the
last poem I've ever written."
Like, I just, I don't know what it is.
So I think we all do it.
We have this kind of self-talk
that just is like, you know,
and I think as I have aged,
I do think I've trusted it.
Like now it's like,
okay, I'm six books in,
they will come and they work in seasons,
and I work in seasons so
that now I trust the silence
so that if it isn't coming,
I just think it's gonna come
and it's gonna come, you know,
for me, I love writing in the spring,
so right now, all the
trees are kind of sleeping,
they're starting to figure
out what they're gonna do,
that's kind of where I'm at.
And then things will come.
So it's a lot about trusting that.
I think the other thing
I think about is that
when people say,
"How could you write
through a time like this?"
Or how it's like really hard right now
where I think about like, you know,
Phyllis Wheatley writing as
a enslaved woman, you know?
I think about Sor Juana Inés
de la Cruz writing, you know,
in Mexico all those years ago,
and like holding her manuscript
to my hands thinking,
this is what she created at this time.
So I'm always like trying to
look at the legacy of others
and how that can inspire us.
Especially when I feel myself
kind of getting down on,
you know, either myself or art in general.
And I always pull myself
up by thinking about
how many people have done so
much in such harrowing times.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] Hi,
thank you so much for being here today.
- Thank you.
- [Audience Member] I had a question
about your background in theater,
because theater is so much about, I guess,
becoming a different character
and becoming a different person,
whereas poetry is about honesty.
And in theater you wanna
sound natural and up on stage,
but in poetry sometimes you
like to play with language
and do different things.
So what was that transition like from you
and do you think theater influences
how you write poetry or vice versa?
- That's a great question.
I have never once regretted
my undergraduate degree in theater.
It was a great experience for me.
I searched on campus,
I went to the University
of Washington in Seattle,
and I remember, you know,
I had come from a town
that was 30,000 people
and I went to a campus
that was 40,000 people.
And I was like, where are my people?
I didn't know, I didn't know what to do.
And I remember sort of walking
into the theater department
and everyone was like just
sort of running around
and like barefoot and laughing
and someone was like
singing opera on the corner.
And I was like, "Oh, I
think I belong here."
And it just felt like this.
We were, you know,
everyone was a little bit,
everyone was interested in making things.
And I think that was actually
probably more healthy for me
at the time than it was in
the creative writing program
because I didn't have that background.
It was a little more, you know,
I think it would've
been I too intimidating
and it might have even put me off.
But, so for me, I think
one of the big things
was that theater teaches you about breath.
It teaches you about communication
and it teaches you about
what it is to sort of stand
in your being, you know,
and be present.
And if the best stage actors can do that
and really embody someone else.
And I think the other part of it was
doing monologues really taught
me a lot about what it was
to write something that
could turn and twist and move
in a short space.
And then the last thing I'll say is,
is that when I did take poetry
in my junior and senior years,
because I had exhausted
the electives I could take
inside the theater
program, they were like,
you need to move on.
I went and I took these
classes and I was like,
"Oh, I love this."
And I had also realized
that for the most part,
I was speaking the words of others, right?
That's what theater is.
And I was also at that time
really primarily working
with the words of older white men.
And so it felt like I had this opportunity
to then write myself into the world.
And it really felt like freedom.
And I think once I found
that kind of freeing space,
I thought, okay, poetry is it.
- [Audience Member] Thank you so much.
Yeah, thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] Hi.
I'm wondering what your
relationship is like
to the speaker of your
poems, and if six books in
that's changed for you?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
I think in order to sort
of protect each other
as we talk about work, we
always use the speaker,
the speaker in the poem is doing this,
the speaker in the poem
is this. And you know,
when I sit down to the
page, I'm the speaker,
And so I feel like it's
okay to conflate the two.
I think sometimes it's
nice to separate that
when we talk about someone else's work
or even if we need to for ourselves,
like the speaker is doing this.
For the most part, I'm very comfortable
with it just being me
and feeling in some ways
that actually the more
human I can get on the page,
the more interesting the
poem might be for myself
as I'm making it.
So I'm trying to actually look
for a little even more intimacy
beyond the word speaker.
But that doesn't mean
sometimes I still wanna keep it
as self protection.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] Hi.
Thank you so much for
the beautiful reading.
- Thank you.
- [Audience Member] I just wanted to ask,
as someone who I find needs
poetry to properly enjoy life
and love life, have you ever had
and someone who finds it
difficult when I can't write
what I need to write? Mm.
Or I am afraid to,
have you ever had moments
in which you feel like you
need to write something but you can't
or you are afraid to write something?
And how did you get through
that and how did that feel?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
Yeah, there have definitely been times
where I felt like I haven't
wanted to write something
or felt like I shouldn't write something.
Who am I to write that?
Or how might this do harm to those I love.
That's probably one of the
biggest things is like,
could this harm someone close to me?
Is it my story to tell or
is it a joint story? Right?
Is it a family story that's not just mine?
There's a lot of those
questions of ethics.
And I'll be honest
that I don't think we
talk about it enough,
because I think that what happens is,
sometimes we as writers
are like, I'm the writer.
I should be able to have
all the freedom I want
to write about whatever I want.
Which is a beautiful thing.
If you're not a human being
that lives with other human beings,
or if you've never had
a human relationship,
then that's fine.
But I think that, if we want
our writing to have impact,
then we also have to be aware
that writing can have consequences.
And I think that we
actually should learn that
because you can write the hard thing,
but unless you're ready
to have that conversation,
then don't share it.
You might need to write it for yourself
and you might need to put it in a drawer.
And I know lots of incredible
poets who have written books,
upon books that are on shelves
and will probably be published
when someone passes away.
And I think that that's okay.
And I think that unless you're ready
to do some deep deeper excavation,
or you're ready to approach
whatever subject it is
that might be terrifying you,
then you may not be ready
to share it with the world.
And that is okay, forcing it never works.
It never works. So I
think it's always good.
Again, the goal is longevity, right?
We want you to write and we
want you to keep writing.
We don't want you to write and be like,
"Oh, well that was traumatic.
Let's not do that again."
Yeah, so I think it's always
a way of protecting yourself,
encouraging yourself, but
making sure that you continue.
- [Audience Member] Thank you so much.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] Hi.
I'm probably like the
hundredth participants person
to say thank you, but
thank you for coming.
- You're welcome. Thank you.
- [Audience Member] You
were talking about earlier,
at the beginning how you pushed back
against a myth of making art alone
and I wanted to ask if there was ever,
if there was a moment or
if there was a process
that made you realize that it was a myth.
Because I feel like it's
very easy to succumb to it
and it's much harder to
internalize that, that feeling.
Also, what's your pugs name?
- Yeah. Okay.
(audience laughing)
Well first of all,
my pug is named Lily
Bean Kudzu Mark Limon.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] Good name.
- And she is amazing.
And she used to travel
with me, but she's 12 now.
And I feel like she just,
all she does is snore and sleep
and it would just be actually distracting
'cause her snore is so loud.
But yeah, she, she's fantastic.
Okay. Well, the other question,
I just got distracted by my pug.
Remind me what you just said before that.
See, I got distracted.
I was like, my pug.
- [Audience Member] It's
okay. Happens to me too.
Just if there was a moment
or a specific process.
- Oh, yes, yes.
You know what it was, it was that,
you sort of, you read literary biographies
or you look at these poets
that have hung out together
or novelists or artist
and you realize like, oh,
all these people were hanging
out together, you know?
Where someone's like,
you meet with someone
and they're like, "Oh yeah,
no, that was my teacher."
You know?
I was like, I always loved Mur Kaiser.
And I remember I studied with Sharon Olds
and Sharon Olds was like, "Yeah,
Mur Kaiser was my teacher."
And I was like, oh, right,
Like this is, this is what this is.
Like, there is so many cycles
and so many communities
and we think of like,
so-and-so being on a pedestal
or this and that and I
just don't think it's true.
And then other thing
is that it's like, yes,
do we have to actually do the work alone?
Yeah, for the most part you do.
That's actually one of the
things I like about it,
'cause it takes a lot to do theater,
it takes a lot of people to make theater.
I get to do my art alone in
my house, in my slippers.
So I think there is that part,
but I think it's really,
I think it was that moment
was in graduate school,
just watching everyone
kind of come together
and be in community.
I didn't have that in the
creative writing as an undergrad.
I had that in theater,
but I didn't know it in creative writing.
But yeah, it came as a graduate school.
- [Audience Member]
Great. Thank you so much.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- Hi.
- Thank you so much again.
This was great.
- Thank you.
- [Audience Member] So I wanted to ask,
I'm going to generalize
a lot, so I apologize.
But I noticed in your poetry
that on one hand you read
a lot about the body,
and on the other hand a lot about nature.
And I was wondering how you
conceptualize the relationship
between the two, is it a boundary,
is it a continuity, is it a mirror?
Like, or is it all of those
things or none of those things?
- Yeah.
I love that question.
I think for me, it kind
of depends on the day.
You know, sometimes I'm like, oh,
this feels like I am in tandem
and connected to everything.
And sometimes I feel like, oh,
I am a machine that is
walking around doing things
with a head full of thoughts
that is very separate, right?
And I'm always trying
to bring them together.
And then there are
moments where I feel like,
oh, I am just as much
animal as that squirrel,
and why am I wearing clothes?
(audience laughing)
Because it's weird that we're
animals that wear clothes.
(audience laughing)
So all of those things.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] Hi,
thank you so much for coming.
Your reading was very moving.
I was reading "The Hurting
Kind" like a few days ago
at the basement of one of our libraries.
And I remember sitting
there for 10 minutes,
but I kind of wanted to
ask about your writing.
And partly because I think a
lot of what you write about
resonates with me in
themes of grief and loss.
And sometimes as a poet,
I personally have had issues
like writing about grief
or loss that isn't my own.
So the only time I have been
able to write or express myself
or release my pain has
been through poetry,
but it has been hard for me
to reconstruct someone else's
pain and then write about it.
And so I was wondering like,
is that something you've done?
Is that something you find
an avenue of poetry from?
And yeah, just want your thoughts.
- Yeah, I think for me, for the most part,
when I'm dealing with
a grief or a lost poem,
it feels like it's either very personal
or it's very collective,
and I have to have some
part of that belongs to me,
some part of it that feels
like, oh, this is also mine.
And whether that's
national grief, you know,
whether that's communal grief.
And so I have to find my
thread and connection to it.
If it's someone else's,
I may not approach it.
That's me as an artist.
And that's also because I'm very wary
of appropriating someone else's pain
in order to perpetuate art.
Not everyone feels that way, but I do.
So I feel like there's
a way in which that I,
it has to feel like it's some
thread of it belongs to me
enough so that I can have
an intimate experience
in the making of it,
and that I feel urgently connected to it.
Otherwise it might feel a little too much
like a project or a manipulation.
Yeah.
- Thank you so much.
- Yeah. Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] Thank you for coming.
And kind of similar to the last question
of having experiences of
grief and pain and loss,
but then wanting to let
those experiences go,
but at the same time, wanting to create
and how there's this situation
where you want to let go,
but then you also want to
create something fasting.
And how do you basically, how
do you deal with that problem?
- Yeah, I think that for
me you have to get curious.
So I find myself in those
situations asking myself,
what is it that wants to hold onto this?
Why this moment?
Why did this person come
back to me right now?
Why does this feel almost like, you know,
something worth living for this pain?
I have to get very curious
about those things.
And it's asking yourself,
okay, is there a lesson here?
Is there something that this
is supposed to teach me?
What's the gift I got from this?
You know, it's starting
to ask those questions
about those losses,
and in doing so unraveling why it is
that they're so
instrumental to who we are.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- Hi.
- [Audience Member] Oh my God.
So you mentioned your friend
of yours named Natalie Diaz,
and am I a correct in assuming
that's the author of
Post-Colonial Love poem?
- Yes.
- Love that book. Love yours as well.
- Yeah, she has,
so Post-Colonial has the
other set of the poems
that are written to each other.
- Oh that's fantastic.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] I'll
go back and look for it.
But there's this line from
Postcolonial Love Poem
that I think about always,
and I'm definitely not gonna
be quoting it word for word,
but it goes something like,
it is real work not to perform a fable,
just ask the turtle, ask the hare.
And I kind of wanted to ask
you whose poems I've read
and seem so free and liberating
and have this sense of
reverence for what is small,
both small and beautiful.
And I kind of wanted to ask how
you negotiate those terms as
someone who maybe does exist
in within the marginalized,
and yeah, just as a writer myself,
I would love to emulate
some of those freedoms
and hear your process.
- Yeah. I think that's really beautiful.
And it's a great question to end on
because I think it's really
essential to how we all work
I think that, as I mentioned earlier
about like how I like to push
against the unhelpful myths.
The things that are like,
this is not helpful to me,
this is not useful to me.
I think in the same way that
as soon as someone wants
to tell me that I need to write
about some specific thing,
I will immediately be like,
"No, I do not need to do that."
And there's this like, wickedness in me
that immediately wants
to deny any part of,
like, when someone is like,
"Oh, you're a Mexican,
so where's your abuela poem,"
and all of these things.
And immediately I'm
like, no, no, no, no, no,
I'm gonna write about this tree
and that's what I'm gonna
write about, you know?
And then sometimes like, you know,
six years later I'll be like,
okay, here's my grandpa poem,
or here's my grandma poem.
But there's these ways
in which that I think,
I'm very suspicious of
what is asked of us as,
especially as writers of color
and how we get put into categories
that don't have anything
to do with beauty, joy,
hope, and freedom.
And I'm very suspicious of the people
who wanna publish trauma
by us, they wanna publish.
They'll only, you know,
write to us when you
have the border story,
write to us when this and
this and this and this.
It's like,
"Well, what if I don't have
any even signifiers in there?
Would you be interested
if it was good work?"
So I'm always pushing
against it and I think
it doesn't mean I don't
interrogate it in my own work,
it doesn't mean it's not
there, but to me it feels,
You know, I grew up at a time as a writer
where every poem that was
published by a black man
in a certain journal, always
had to have a bullet in it
in order to get published, right?
And if you were Latinx,
you better have (speaks in Spanish)
Like it was like this very,
and it was like, oh my God,
this is in these big journals
that I shouldn't name,
(audience laughing)
and I saw that,
and I remember very early on being like,
I want everyone else's freedom.
And guess what? They can't give it to me.
I can only take it for myself.
- [Audience Member] Thank
you. That was wonderful.
- Thank you.
(audience clapping)
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
(audience clapping continues)
(gentle digital music)